Varvara and Mar
(Barcelona)
We use technology and code as art materials
Just like the sculptor uses clay as a material
In fact, this intangible material is extremely powerful.
Recently we used the phrase "we are creators"
Our strange ideas
Ask us to create a tool that didn’t exist before
The reason we started to cooperate
Because it can make our creativity more complete.
Sometimes I will get inspiration
But the inspiration is primitive and incomplete.
So we worked together to shape the inspiration
We have different skills
For example, I am very obsessed with electronics and welding.
Also like to use philosophical methods
And Marr is a programming genius.
I love the code very much.
Think of the code as a craft
One day without writing code, it will be uncomfortable the next day.
Code can do everything
Because the code is the soul of the computer
Cooperation allows us to look at it from another angle
Examine our work
We use a lot of different brain-computer interfaces. This is called neural structure.
Is to create directly through the ideas in the mind
In fact, through collaboration
You will open your own world and open a new audience.
May even open new areas
To us
The DevArt project is our first use of speech and interaction
The core concept is
The interaction process is amazing
You just need to say your wish system and you can hear it.
Then a butterfly will magically appear
Just like making your wishes come true
After being appointed
You will be working side by side with Varvara and Marl of the Barbican Art Centre in London.
The art of code creation